passed through jerusalem's jaffa gate
into the maze of the old city and abed
baccarat shop
is the first on the right he's 85 now
a jerusalemite who's lived through so
many challenges here over the years
but nothing prepared him for covid when
was the last time you sold
some some products to a tourist six
month
six months
now i come in here
this day i don't like to stay in the
home
his is the universal struggle of 2020
empty businesses broken livelihoods and
that needs somehow to stay busy
and stay sane through the year these
paths at the heart of the holy land
should be packed with visitors
tourists and pilgrims following the
roots of their religions
and yet for ten whole months there has
been not one
how is business not good
not good no good
[Music]
the roofs above the alleyways are where
you'll find the best views here
but these days the spot for the snap
everyone wants is deserted
the church of the holy sepulchre marks
the place where christians believe
jesus was crucified and then rose from
the dead
inside today it's empty
hi how are you
karen is originally from liverpool
jerusalem is now home where she runs the
levantine gallery
and she's holding on to hope that people
will soon return
they stopped at various times due to
wars due to plague
uh then during the world wars
um the political unrest the entifadas
but they always come back here because
this is a unique city
and it's got these sites of faith
or pilgrimage for the three monotheistic
religions but that history and the
political complexities of this region
make things even harder past
idle tour buses the road to bethlehem
takes you through israeli checkpoints
into the occupied palestinian
territories where the economy was
struggling even before
covid in manger square the tree is up
but there will be no visitors
and locals are not allowed to gather as
they usually do
midnight mass at the church of the
nativity is restricted to just a few
people are sad people are worried people
are now thinking of their daily income
tony kashran is the president of the
local tourist association
and he has just one message well i i
would say get vaccinated and come
you know we we we love to see you here
we love to see pilgrims we love to see
tourists back
we want to go back to normal and the
people i mean everybody knows
the the holy land everybody knows the
areas here
just come come back
and yet despite all this or maybe
because of it
it's hope not despair which seems to
endure
kavit 19 made the people think back
about
how they have to love each other around
the world
we are all a human being if it's hurt
you will hurt me
that's it solidarity works um
around food because of course no
christmas is complete without food and
for that
in bethlehem look no further than the
founder restaurant
and chef fadi catan and fowder
means soda which means chaos
and it's called chaos because
how i used to do the menu here is i go
meet the farmers
whatever they have that day is how my
menu looks and
it's a bit this creative chaos that we
have but now it's a
quiet guess yeah and all together
different chaos
a very different chaos um the chaos
where we're wondering about
what's going to be happening next year
okay
well that's going to your kitchen and
see what you can cook
i mean the market is wrong with the
restaurant shut we're off to faddy's
home
for some comfort food palestinian style
my butcher's a local butcher
i've slow cooked um
shelters
that have been oh wow easily cooking for
the last
look at that four and a half hours
and i guess for you like your passion is
cooking and that's been kind of your
escape as well
of course i i just after we closed the
restaurant
i had to come up with something to stay
sane here
but also to be able to share what i'm
doing
i'm not physically cooking for other
people but with with how things have
changed
through the different online platforms i
think i've fed
more people over the last few months
that i've done in the last five years
that's for me that's the message of
christmas from bethlehem
um this year i hope for people
wherever they are if you're cooking cook
a bit more
and share it with somebody who actually
is going through a rough time
cook a larger leg of lamb or you know
have the turkey cut up in a way where
you could send them a meal or
you know send a family a meal or
something solidarity
i think so let's eat that's it fantastic
mark stone sky news in bethlehem